[Music]
running or executing softwares or
applications with the aim of finding out
errors or bugs in the developed
application is called software testing
selenium and qtp are two software
testing tools used widely in the current
software industry
let's do a comparison between these two
testing tools in this video
in this session we will be going through
what is selenium
what is qtp then we'll have a comparison
between selenium and qtp
we'll then try to understand why one
should shift to selenium
and finally how to migrate from qtp to
selenium
so
what do you mean by selenium to put it
in simple terms selenium is an open
source testing program for web-based
applications spread across different
platforms and browsers
selenium is a set of four components
that are usually required at the time of
software testing
they are
selenium integrated development
environment or ide
this is a web browser add-on that
creates tests very quickly through its
record and playback functionality
depreciated selenium remote control rc
this is a test tool that allows you to
write automated web application ui tests
in any programming language against any
http website using any mainstream
javascript enabled browser webdriver
this is used for cross browser testing
and selenium grid
this is used for cross platform testing
so what is qtp
qtp is a testing tool developed by
havelet packard
it stands for quick test professional
identifying errors problems or gaps with
respect to the expected results of any
software that is being tested are the
functions of the hp qtp
vbscript is used by qtp for automation
purposes and it need not be installed
separately as it comes along with the
windows os
the latest version of qtp is called uft
and it is a combination of hpqtp and hp
service test
hudsons and jenkins are two open source
continuous integration system that is
supported by uft
it also provides support for mobile
testing
uft mobile support
allows to create agnostic scripts that
is scripts compliant with for all mobile
platforms this script developed in ios
can also be run on android let us now
have a comparison between hp qtp and
selenium
hpqtp is a famous tool in the market of
web-based testing but with the dawn of
selenium's popularity and its ability to
do more than qtp ever could has made it
a worthy competitor
these are quite a few straightforward
differences between qtp and selenium
that might help people choose between
the two
qtp is used commercially and hence it
requires license while selenium is an
open source tool and is free for
everyone to use
qtp can be used to test both web paste
and desktop application
while selenium can only come in handy
while testing web-based applications
only qtp ide can be used while doing qtp
test
while in case of selenium tests multiple
ides can be used like netbeans visual
studio eclipse
qtp can only support vbscripts while
selenium supports multiple programming
languages like dotnet ruby perl php java
javascript etc qtp supports multiple
types of dialog box while selenium can
only support dialog box partially
developing time is high in selenium than
qtp
authentication windows can be automated
in uft whereas in selenium we have to
use auto id or use robot class in java
qtp has a very good official technical
support while selenium has community
technical support
qtp is comparatively more user friendly
and the scripts can be developed in a
short time on the other hand selenium
has less functionality as it is low
level and the scripts take up more time
to come and to be maintained
hp uft is a tool used to integrate qtp
on the other hand selenium does not have
any tool used for integration
speaking of execution qtp can test one
application per machine whereas selenium
can execute multiple tests on a machine
at the same time
moreover selenium takes lesser cpu and
ram power in the time of execution as
compared to qtp
so why should one then shift to selenium
a slight modification in the code has to
be tested to make sure that the code is
running fine and fulfilling the target
now repeating the tests again and again
can get costly the high portability of
selenium allows the automation engineers
to write codes without worrying about
the os
the testing is ideally kept
self-contained within the program and
they can be modified as desired this
approach makes sure that any change in
quotes does not increase the development
and improves maintainability
the flexibility offered by selenium
allows coders to manage tests better
since selenium is open source users can
extend share and modify codes thus
saving a great deal of time and effort
for the programmers
so how to migrate from qtp to selenium
choose the script language keeping the
team's experience and the relevant kind
of automation framework in mind
put off building frameworks and write
simple selenium scripts in the beginning
keep tracks of the issue that come up
with time and make use of the solutions
to build larger test suites in future
once comfortable with selenium start
discovering tools that can be used with
selenium for example maven test ng etc
making a choice between qtp and selenium
might be a very difficult job because of
so many advantages and disadvantages but
it is quite evident that selenium
ensures a better payback and versatility
as compared to qtp
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos to nerd up and get certified
click here